so scientology was completely weird mind
[ __ ]
it's an evil cult um
they if you don't know i'm going to tell
you anyway um
i'm well aware they um
they believe um that um
75 million years ago
an evil uh space alien lord called lord
sonu
brought space aliens to earth and um
killed them with h-bombs in volcanoes
but the
spiritual remains of those space aliens
called thetans have stuck to us
and caused madness in humanity et cetera
et cetera and only scientology
will clear you of this and if i tell
anybody this
i will die and they may die because of
the power of the story
and frankly i've been doing little else
since 2007
in any pub in london or manchester
or wherever i am in the world somebody
sits me down and then i start telling
them about scientology
and here i am i'm still very much alive
so i am living proof that scientology is
a load of bollocks
have you answered the question are you a
member of the church i am not a member
of the church okay right go go go
okay we can carry on talking yeah so
mike rinder
is you know we're great friends mike and
i he's been on my podcast
yeah so mike um
left he owes me a lot mike left the
church of scientology because of me
i would say i don't know you have have
you seen have you seen the film
we made which is on youtube i i have not
seen the film that you guys made
uh the i've seen uh the hbo documentary
going clear
yes so by the way if you're if people
are super nutty about scientology they
can
uh watch the two films which i think are
flying around on youtube
one of which is called the first one is
scientology in me
in which i scream the second is
um scientology secrets of
of the stars mike's uh big in that
and then i've written a book called uh
scientology church of fear which you can
get there amazon
and the um
maybe we can do some linky things so you
people can see this stuff
absolutely um but so what happens is
that
excuse me when i screamed at scientology
because they made me go nuts
there were two pr men who were on my
coast the whole time tommy davis is the
guy i screamed at directly
but standing next to him looking grey
and ashen the whole time was mike rinder
and mike rinder had been in the hole and
when i arrived in the states
um david miscavige the pope of
scientology got him out of the hole
to handle me to deal with me mike rinder
was in that video when you're screaming
at the guy
it is he is on the edge if you if you
watch the whole
30-minute documentary okay so
mike rinder is the other is the other
minder
and what happened was that um
essentially there were dozens of them
there was only a normal bbc thing
bbc by the way uh i [ __ ] about it all
the time it's a lovely thing
i still believe in it and i still pay my
licence fee
um there was a brilliant producer called
sarah mole
and there was a fantastic um
cameraman called bill brown uh the
production was from bbc northern ireland
and so um um bill's
from belfast and all of the bbc northern
irish cameramen are fantastically brave
because they do in the 70s and 80s they
did riots all the time
so that's their upbringing they're
really really good
anyway um sarah has a plan
which is she's from essex i'm going to
um
uh do her accent for you here john
you seen jurassic park aren't ya
i have sarah so in jurassic park
there's that bit isn't there where
there's a goat and it's tethered
and then the t-rex comes and gets it
right then you can bleak can't ya
so my job was to be the tethered ghost
and what we would do because she'd
analyzed it she'd watched
scientology attack people like me who
were trying to investigate them
and what they would do was ambush
somebody like me
in the middle of the night which
scientology did
when you put the camera away so we were
defenseless
what happened was that sarah made it a
rule that
whenever we were out i had
um the two of us bill had his big camera
and sierra had a small camera and they
were
fully charged and on at all times and if
the big camera wasn't charging
we'll put it down because we're going
for a meal at the very end of the day
so would have the little small camera in
case something happened this is
before mobile phones really got going
2007.
and before there were phones and video
and mobile phones
so also i had two
sound mics on me um with two back
packs in case one failed by the way
going to the loo
with two bloody sand mics it's like it's
like
something nightmare it's like a scene in
chernobyl
um it's just like bloody annoying anyway
those are the rules because she knew
that they would come for us and lo and
behold they came for us at midnight at
the hotel but
we filmed it and and i um
i'm good at this stuff and i and i fired
back
and i said listen you've been spying of
us and this is a bit creepy frankly
um anyway it's it was a fantastic battle
um and i was the tethered goat
and eventually i got sick of the [ __ ]
and the tethered goat turned into a
tethered rhino and i [ __ ] charged
them
that's the show and all of that the bbc
thought about sacking me
but then they thought about solid let's
go for it this is before twitter
2007 the film goes out and then you get
hundreds and hundreds of emails
from max members of the church who fall
in love with maybe
who um and two emails i love in
particular one is mr sweeney you're my
hero
but then i am the vice president of the
rural college of psychiatry
because psychiatrists get in the net
from scientology
and therefore i became a pinup of
international psychiatry because i had
to go
at scientology it's so
go ahead i found it so fascinating that
mike render actually
spent time with l ron hubbard and
did he he didn't tell me that but he was
in
he was actually met him yeah he didn't
uh he didn't tell me that anyway what
happened was
at one point i because we had hours and
hours and hours
of them coming us me filming them
they're trying to
they're trying to break me and to break
me they bring me in a bit
into into the scientology tent and then
break me and sarah
and bill my colleagues um
ah they film everything we've got so
much in the cam
we start having uh we we kind of
stopped filming and one of these moments
i asked
uh tommy davis and mike render
could i interview david miscavige he by
the way is the pope of scientology but
unlike for example
the pope in rome david miscavige is
alleged he denies
around smacking people he would like he
get pissed off
with me he'd smack me if i was a member
of the church that's what people
mike rinder says that happened to him
bang
bang bang and um
um i say i'd like to interview david
miscavige i want to interview your pope
and mike rinder says well you're not
going to do that john because and i said
why not because you're an [ __ ]
at which point sarah the essex girl
who's got a wonderful sense of humor
goes
and she loses it just likes giggling and
bill
who's a much tougher who is
sarah they're both tough but bill who's
a tough looking guy
starts to laugh too and both of them are
corpsing
because of uh i'm not interviewing
scientology
because i'm an [ __ ]
but mike rinder realized
that although my team were mocking me
taking the piss out of me
as we say in english english they also
kind of had my back and they kind of you
know we loved each other
we liked each other and we were a gang
and in our gang the um
the two people behind the camera
couldn't take the piss out of me could
mock me
and and we still liked each other it was
still good fun
it didn't matter it was normal but in
his
gank he had to express failure
to the pope he had to he could never
mock him he could never
he could never give he could never be a
normal human
being and i think that was the moment
when mike realized he'd rather be in
the bbc's gang than in the scientology
gang
after a lot of heartbreak for mike
because it meant
breaking with his family who was still
inside
his mother his sister and his brother
his kids he left and three years later
he sat down and i interviewed him
and he told me everything what was
frustrating at the time was the power of
the bbc
oh sorry british libel laws meant that
we couldn't put in the smacking
allegations and it was actually
alex gibney and lawrence wright who did
that story
um in the ongoing clip but i'm in the
going clear documentary
which is so properly unfair so
rigorous about scientology they have
them shouting at me but not me shouting
at them which
strikes me as being a bit funny but but
there we go anyway you
um if people aren't interested they
should chase those films
we made for panorama the first one we
did was in 2007
so although going clear we got bigger
punches
we um we attacked scientology first
and of that i'm very proud
foreign